Look, can you see them, Emma?
Oh, hi!
How can I be a good boyfriend?
Well, just even by asking the question you're an amazing boyfriend.
I think really it's just being kind...
...in any way that you can.
And dancing!
Oh, you should dance with her!
Boys that dance are so great.
Lovely to meet you both.
Good luck!
How do I drop my career and become an actor?
What do you think?
That's awesome.
You seem like the kind of person you'd wanna watch.
I want to be a film director.
Do what you love and make films about what you love.
You can argue  yourself into making decisions...
...that don't have heart behind  them and they're never the right ones.
Just always follow the things that feel the most right to you.
Thank you so much.
Pleasure.
Emma, how was that?
It was awesome.
I think you gave very good advice.
Thanks, Derek.
What am I gonna do with all this stuff?
Oh my God, the money!
It has to go to Planned Parenthood.
Planned Parenthood.
You got it.
They're the best.
Any other last-minute advice?
Keep loving life, New York City.
You're the greatest city in the world.